hello and welcome to this video till you
bombay yeah it's not so easy to win with
the picture off against solid play but
let's see if I can't do something here
you don't get the get the main on this
that I actually don't know all that well
okay but should be three is uncommon hmm
there so he's not doing anything very
aggressive here with C 3 and so on
I wonder Bishop to g4 maybe c6 is a
generally quite useful move okay so here
Texas noise
yeah I'm just going to cover it I mean
you have this outpost only form in the
petrov you essentially in this line you
have a you are a tempo up in a way yeah
you have you have 94 in already
but why it's turn is to show that this
is a liability
Wow canceling long that's interesting
yeah I definitely need to get something
going myself on the queenside v 585 or
how do we do that oh I'm sorry my grave
I'm not just winning upon yeah rook
takes pawn up huh
oh it says some trickery f3 at the end
oh no it's just hanging at the moon and
I take it you two
so no Oh Queen takes Knight takes Bishop
takes Bishop takes Queen takes is the
idea I didn't see that before
beforehand I know
that okay Knight takes Bishop takes
Bishop takes ahead Queen f4 check so
here if I take on D - okay I have to do
that anyway can take on G when f5 and h7
is hanging it's not a big problem I can
go here and now Bishop h7 is just giving
me material basically after King h8 I'm
threatening Queen h6 check winning the
bishop and that's 93 so I don't think
this is going to work out all that well
for white especially considering that 93
is a fork on all three pieces yeah all
three not not noise
no not much not much that you can do
you know it's taking a long time when
it's basically over
so let's win the piece and it's a it's a
queen trade at the same time which is
which is nice and by the way I'm still
going to take life so another thing
everyone maybe have something else but I
just take it so yeah so the first time
he thought it was already gone yeah here
in this line here with Bishop d6 it is
really as I mentioned it's like yeah
this is it like a tempo up like is
having this 94 move however this is not
all an upside yeah it's nice to have
this night in a way but why it gets to
play against this piece and against the
stability here in the center what he
should do is castle castle see form and
this is the only way to challenge this
thing this whole line with Bishop d6
then black go c6 and now White has tried
various ways to put pressure on on this
93 Queen c2 rook e1 all those moves are
very logical and they're the theory
basically starts something slow like
this is giving black instant instant
equality because you have the knight on
e4 it's nice to have and here I'm just a
little bit more active again it's
nothing special it's being more active
in a symmetrical position what I have
now is basically they are like a French
exchange where I'm white I'm a little
bit ahead ok Knight bTW - rook e8 Yan
long castle so I was surprising um
it's playable I guess I don't think it's
terrible
engine doesn't like it ok 97 yeah now
something normal instead of 95 which
failed I was expecting him to play Age 3
actually trying to get in G form and I
would have played b5 him and try to
start a counter-attack I'm not entirely
certain but it might be that I'm a
little bit that my attack is maybe more
dangerous because there is actually some
witness here with c3 and MAV my cutie is
entirely entirely sound it's still
nothing special
like g4 maybe imp the engine wants to
take on the to no one to stop Bishop d6
okay not sure h4 it's not clear computer
is very relaxed here like this is good
yeah but what happens after this then I
can take this is not easily done in a
blitz game this kind of this kind of
play I mean once you see that there is
no like this is not working I can take
f3
yeah then things are nice but here this
is this is kind of clear that I'm fine
but yeah it's also easy then 95
basically doesn't work but I did not
really Bishop takes them stronger okay
what I didn't see beforehand is that
here going back cake cake
um that was close yeah like this I
cannot play with this movie then I'm
losing but I have this one Queen f4
chick and I didn't see that beforehand
so I was a bit lucky that that worked
and yeah I'm just taking and you know
this is winning from black cannot save
the material I'm winning at least an
exchange on e3 okay guys thanks for
watching